hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo la
salud a juliet riaño
[Música]
la idea de levantar un muro en las
fronteras no deja de ser una opción para
los gobiernos que buscan detener la
migración irregular hacia sus
territorios aunque el más conocido está
en norteamérica entre méxico y eeuu
otros se construye en la región
república dominicana ya comenzó las
obras de sumerja en la frontera noreste
con haití una medida que el gobierno
justifica por motivos de seguridad pero
que al final se trata de una barrera
física para alejar cada vez más a un
vecino que está en crisis veamos más en
el informe de luís muñoz
un nuevo muro contra la migración
república dominicana inició el 20 de
febrero la construcción de una verja
fronteriza inteligente el presidente
luis abinader celebró la medida desde la
ciudad fronteriza de dajabón
sin embargo la república dominicana no
puede hacerse cargo de la crisis
política económica de ese país ni
resolver tampoco el resto de sus
problemas
apostando por la vía legal como la única
forma posible de entrar en nuestro
territorio una frontera regulada es una
frontera mucho más segura para este
proyecto se destinarán 31 millones de
dólares la verja será un muro de
hormigón y con una estructura metálica
de 3,90 metros
en la primera fase se esperan construir
54 kilómetros con 19 torres de
vigilancia y 10 puertas de patrullaje
después habrá una segunda fase donde se
construirán 110 kilómetros de valla más
cubriendo 160 de los 380 kilómetros de
frontera que tiene república dominicana
con haití
ante esta noticia los haitianos se
apuran para cruzar el paso fronterizo
este proyecto había sido anunciado hace
alrededor de un año por el presidente
quien ha hecho política de gobierno al
control fronterizo
precisamente el 7 de julio tras el
asesinato del presidente de haití en el
mois llegó a cerrar completamente la
frontera
sin embargo esta gestión migratoria está
siendo rechazada por organizaciones
internacionales a finales de 2021 600
activistas de república dominicana y más
de 20 países firmaron un documento
llamado las vidas haitianas importan
en el texto se condena la deportación de
mujeres embarazadas capturadas junto a
hospitales además de la suspensión del
programa de visados para universitarios
haitianos todo esto cuando en 2021
fueron deportados más de 31 mil
haitianos
pero no sólo en américa latina' los
muros se levantan para dividir fronteras
en el mundo hay varios ejemplos de los
que se erigieron y ya no están y los que
son construidos en la actualidad
restringir la movilidad es el fin en
todos los casos hubo un día en el que la
caída del muro de berlín fue vista en
todo el mundo como un acto de libertad
pero lo que entonces se celebró terminó
por caer en el olvido y hoy en 2022 se
están construyendo nuevos muros en todo
el mundo uno de los más destacados está
en plena europa polonia quiere detener
la entrada de emigrantes desde belarús
son 186 kilómetros de valla para una
frontera de 418 cinco metros y medio de
altura para los que se han destinado
353 millones de euros se espera que las
obras terminen en junio organizaciones
de derechos humanos denuncian su
construcción
el muro solo detiene a los
discapacitados a los débiles a los
enfermos no impide que las personas
desesperadas que huyen del peligro
intenten cruzar
los muros generalmente no funcionan
es donde mire una brigada la frontera
con méxico o egipto donde sea que haya
un muro hay una ciudad subterránea
debajo de él
underground city internet esta activista
nombraba a gaza' precisamente israel
finalizó en diciembre de 2021 la
construcción de su sofisticado muro
después de tres años de construcción el
muro de hierro de 65 kilómetros cuenta
con todo tipo de tecnologías de
reconocimiento y tiene hasta una parte
subterránea para evitar túneles en su
forma de ampliar el bloqueo a la franja
de gaza palestina controlada desde 2007
por hamás hatem sí mucho la onu una de
nuestras misiones es estar un paso por
delante del enemigo en el aire en el mar
y en el ciberespacio en la tierra e
incluso en el subsuelo si es necesario
otro país que está construyendo un nuevo
muro es turquía lo hace en la provincia
de ban frontera con irán y una puerta de
entrada al país son 64 kilómetros que se
sumarán a los 144 ya amurallados en una
frontera de 295 kilómetros de longitud
se amplificaron en 2021 después de la
toma talibán de kabul pero es una
práctica que turquía ya realizada en la
frontera con siria para evitar la
llegada de inmigrantes que huían
desesperados de la guerra
al final la historia demuestra que
construir muros en las fronteras para
disuadir la migración no es una solución
para contener el tránsito y el dato de
migración de la semana el instituto
nacional de inmigración de méxico detuvo
a más de 5000 migrantes en sólo una
semana en tránsito por su territorio de
ellos
793 eran menores de edad los detenidos
provenían de 23 países la mayoría de
centro y suramérica también se
reportaron asiáticos y africanos
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]